moving on to your your choice oh yeah
constantly
oh my god i have wanted to talk about
this
for so long never laughed that hard
you know what sad is that i've
legitimately watched this and nutted to
a scene in it are you
who's like for some reason the the
armpit gets zoomed in way too [ __ ]
close
that was weird i felt comfort because
what happened was like i didn't i'm
watching this right i'm 10 minutes in
and okay we should explain the premise
we should how do we even explain what
okay so it's a about a bunch of pervs
who are teachers and those
school kids aren't into it and then
there's another side plot where there's
police and terrorists
and then a terrorist gets there's a
weird gun fight which is just so we'll
talk about that yeah
and then and then they kill the
terrorists and terrorists has this bomb
and it explodes and then it makes
everyone horny and then everyone starts
[ __ ]
it's like a horny virus yeah but also
when the bomb goes off dubstep just
starts playing yeah yeah yeah
i'm way too loud dubstep okay okay
the way the way i did would describe the
center i don't i wouldn't
i would never recommend the sentai it's
awful to like nuts it was definitely
not where i'm like oh god this this is
the room
okay how i would describe this is
imagine if it's the name again
sodom so like if i were to put a tagline
it is
imagine if masaki iwasa directed
directed a hentai shitpost
that is that is canton sodom because it
is
like it is way too funny to be
that for this to like not it was weird
i wrote down it's like a hentai parody
of tikkon kin creeps
that's what i said like yeah because it
gave me tickle king revives but for the
worst reasons
but like it had some scenes in it where
the comedic timing
oh wait it was way too great so why did
you choose your list just because you
want to talk about because i just like i
i want i wanted to
because this this this show is just pure
bands so you've never nodded to it
i've i've never i'm really glad you
recommended this because now i like
want to watch the rest of it just to see
how bad this is this is the type of
another episode
apparently no no this is this is the
only one oh really i saw canton sodom
one and i tried to look for episode two
i'm like
[ __ ] man i wish there was an episode two
this is the one of a kind [ __ ]
because this is the type of hentai
you're just like you can you can only
recommend to boys you truly trust
and if you're gonna watch it it's only
at like when at 3am when you're [ __ ]
pissed
okay and you're just like can you can
recommend something weird and funny
the teacher scene was [ __ ] good oh my
god come on it was though come on
no it's not you know you don't think so
no the entire the entire time i was
laughing my ass off
because how could you get it how could
you get a stiffy when it was just that
[ __ ]
this was the only this was the only one
on the list where i was soft as a pillow
i
do not remember any anything else in
this for somehow
are you serious somehow i did not
recommend this show so you can [ __ ]
not to where
is it no no no no no no no no no why
isn't that when connor sees the milf
it's just tunnel vision
it is totally well i watched this like
two years ago but i do not remember i
must have skipped every other scene
and then when i found this scene and
then when i got to the scene i must have
been like
all right 0.7 cap speed because because
i remember i remember the
the way i discovered this was i saw it
on pornhub yeah and it was just like a
clip i was just like oh this looks like
because the animation style
is like very unique it's it's a very
very you also it's very you are so that
kind of like that kind of close stuff
yeah and i was like
you know i've like because the the thing
about a lot of hensar is that it all
looks [ __ ] squeaky clean
it all looks flatter [ __ ] this one like
i will give some chunk to it yeah this
one's got some chunk to it it's got some
it's got some like direct
directorial choices in it i will i will
say that it hit me like a [ __ ] truck
when that teacher popped up and i was
like
they're not like not past south was like
oh my god i've nodded to this
but like for like this they were
supposed to be a comedy
i am 100 percent convinced that this
is a comedy there there is no [ __ ]
way i felt like after i watched it i was
like [ __ ] i felt like i
nudded to cars too you know what i mean
this is embarrassing
that i've did this but i'm gonna say
re-living childhood and realize that's
like way different because like
all the other scenes were just
disgusting and like it wasn't even
disgusting
they were kind of disgusting the little
girl with the [ __ ] guy who's like
delivering packages all the janitor guys
like when she was sucking his [ __ ] and
she looked like a literal horse
when she looked like a little like a
literal horse
sucking on her so gross
the scene that [ __ ] killed me is like
the teacher who took a photo
of the girls like underwear and he's
like jacking it in the toilet
and the phone turns to one percent and
he speeds up
and then it cuts to this it cuts this
[ __ ] shootout
that's happening and they interject the
shootout with this teacher
jacking off and it's so [ __ ]
hilarious i also love the shootout scene
because there's like
two cops with a [ __ ] handgun right
yeah and there's one girl with the
[ __ ] assault rifle
how does it end one shot each yeah also
it's going on for like six
seconds and none of them shoot each
other and then just like the the
shootout well
you have to watch the shootout because
it's just like bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang
and the [ __ ] clip where like the two
girls arguing over who's gonna [ __ ] this
one teacher yeah oh yeah and then she
turns around the girl just [ __ ]
decks her in the face she just passes
out
and she's like all right teacher now we
can [ __ ]
it's like stop messing with him he's
like what are your best i was like
like the [ __ ] like you know the
squidward where it's like squidward hot
and squidward like yeah yeah
yeah i was like screwed in normal
throughout with when the teacher scene
came on i was like the hot like cheering
guys i like oh my god it's hot man it's
hot
i'm [ __ ] amazed that united states no
because there was i looked at the
the beginning of the teacher scene right
where she's standing over the guy
and she has this like she has like the
[ __ ] juice
that is just like that's [ __ ] weird
which is she's just like literally is
she like
is is this [ __ ] drops of god or
something she's pouring this [ __ ] juice
from such a height
and it's just like one long string that
i'm like
this is the thing with hentai though
because it's so often not like 100 what
you want it to be
right you take the good with the bad
when you found a premise that works
all right if she [ __ ] takes a [ __ ] on
him for a second all right i'll look
past it because it's 10 seconds right
i'll just
i'll forget about it though no i mean
i'll be there
but i'll get over it yeah it's like when
that happens it's like i'm willing to
look past this
[Music]
i'm just i'm just [ __ ] amazed that
you're this is zoned into like the milf
team
that like you managed to you managed to
actually not to be
it is the most insane tunnel vision i've
ever seen i i i
i'm managing to nudge a [ __ ] looney
tunes porn man or something yeah
no no because if you take if you did
okay if you were given
just that scene right with none of the
other scenes
right right because i don't remember the
the bomb going off or anything like this
i'm pretty sure i would [ __ ] remember
dubstep in my head
i would remember that right so somehow i
just watched this scene
and none of the others and when you take
just that scene with the teacher it's
like
it's easy to see why yeah i think yeah
why you could go away and you know maybe
no why
because they look like because it looks
like because it looks like someone made
a a penta parody of a mask like you or
some film
that's what it looks like like i've said
dude i can the animation does not matter
to me
it is the premise and how that delivers
on the premise
i can i dude i'm starting to think that
you can just jack off no no because as
long as there's another
if the taboo is there joey 100 what
we've got an older woman right
check there's danger but doing at the
time i didn't know everyone was [ __ ]
i just
i just thought she was going at it in
the school yeah right right that's hot
extra points
right and then not gonna lie she's a
she's in a she's
abusing a power a position of power
right yeah that's hot she was a thick
mama
oh dude she was real thick man that's
yeah what what what's the perfect
trifecta
yeah but then i look at that blue thick
older woman
but then like i think all of that right
like by itself i see all of that lined
up and i'm like yeah i could probably
jack off to that but then
it's topped up with the drops of god and
the fact that
you know we're really weird zoom in on
the armpit i don't know what that was
about listen you cannot complain right
about
like a bit of juice coming down right
when you were you [ __ ] jacked off to
ten goblins [ __ ]
it was just it was just the fact that it
like they really
i think my biggest problem that i have
with this is just i don't know who was
in charge of the [ __ ] audio mixing on
this episode but
my god it was [ __ ] fun that [ __ ]
through levellator or some [ __ ] but it
came out
no no no no i feel like it was purposely
yeah purposefully there was like
half the scenes there was no like
background music everything about this
hentai was i feel just like a master
class in being like the
ultimate car crash of a hentai oh yeah
it is
pure [ __ ] garbage it's hilarious it
was fun for the family had a little
something forever
so funny or something wrong what about
that scene where like they're [ __ ]
the teachers [ __ ]
and like they have like this close-up
zoom in of her armpits
okay that was weird i don't know i
didn't get that because i thought it was
like you know like it was something like
oh it's going to come up later the
armpit's going to be right
but it wasn't it wasn't just yeah and i
was like why
and then it just like it just it just it
just ended so randomly
it ends with a guy blowing off a guy's
head off and then a girl randomly comes
in and just spot and kicks this dude on
the helicopter i was like
what there just is and then it just ends
and i'm like what no no context no
[ __ ]
epilogue or anything it just ends i
think i think i rated this higher than
any of joey's
are you serious oh yeah i rated this uh
oh my god i'm never recommending you
ever again what's it called
a seven out of ten but i recommend i
recommend that like
i recommend to watch that if you want a
[ __ ] hilarious laughter
all right also maybe a cheeky not you
know maybe no i recommend
i honestly like normally you don't
recommend watching hentai with the boys
this is a hentai you can watch
this one you can watch because it's so
funny at 3am at your next [ __ ] anime
convention when you just want to [ __ ]
laugh
at how shitty this hentai is or if
you're conor just like
sneak off to the bathroom to like get
like wrapped up like i'm laughing like
i really want to get the rights to it so
we can make like a hentai parody dub
oh my god if we are able to dump it that
way
that would be like the perfect parody
dub hentai
it's like it's it's already structured
itself it's like
it's like the ghost stories of him
exactly yeah it's perfect
it's already perfectly structured i
loved my favorite part like i don't know
why this made me laugh so much is that
they cut to a shot of like where the
gunfight is
the school and like the hospital
something and they're all like
they're the only three buildings it's
like a child's play mat
like the way that these are arranged i'm
like there's a gun fight happening in
like an abandoned and there's a single
road
that's all over the place it's like damn
okay they really don't give a [ __ ]
yeah where's the school located no
because i i kind of realized early on
that they must be doing this on purpose
this is i think so i think yeah because
i remember like the first joke where
the they're like the two girls are in
the train and out of nowhere a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] stripper or something comes out
or
like it's like yeah jesus and then
like the girl kicks him and then he just
like stands there for a full like
five seconds and then nuts it was it was
that pause before the nut that was just
like god the character designs are so
ugly
and then and then the two girls like
and then like one of the girl got nutted
on you don't see her changing but she
was in a school uniform
and then she's in like she's in gym
clothes the next club
the next shot and there's like and then
and then the girls in front of the
[ __ ] company are like does something
smell like
and then they walk for smart and then
it's just the walking animation where
they're just like
the speed ups [ __ ] killing me it was
good i i really enjoyed it
yeah it was i've wanted to talk about
this for so long because i've no one's
i've no one i've ever like
talked to has ever like recommended or
talked about this hentai because
it is such a funny hentai and i've wait
i've waited for this opportunity where i
can be like yo bros
what is one hentai you're going to lose
your mind because like when you when
when you when you go to someone and
you're like yo i gotta like
i got a [ __ ] amazing hentai you need
to watch you need to trust the bros
there
of course and the bros need to trust you
because otherwise they're just not gonna
watch it so
i highly recommend watching this one
show it is hilarious you're gonna have a
great [ __ ] time i had a [ __ ] fanta
i'm not gonna lie i watched it twice
just because it was so funny i was like
there must have been other like nuggets
that i missed along the way
i did not watch it twice one was enough
to remind me of my shame